don't tell situation in this kind of
situation with a massive inflow hot
spots just can't handle all the arrivals
so our presidency has been thinking
about some other concept that could work
which is the idea of a processing center
which could apply a cross throughout the
whole route so a processing center now
that whole concept has to be explored
and further defined however processing
centers of this kind could exist right
along their route and help migrants with
the asylum applications or make sure
that they are returned there is a right
to asylum in the European Union and we
can only underscore that this is a
fundamental characteristic of the
European Union but even though that does
exist the migrant can not take advantage
of that right and if they refuse to
cooperate with the authorities there is
no choice there is no freedom to choose
their country of final destination
either they can't expect to be able to
choose the European Union has to be able
to use its relocation mechanism and the
redistribute migrants on the basis of
this European concept let me be clear
far away from our minds to set up
detention centers what's all about
talking about this processing centers
the support services within third
countries because within the member
states of the European Union we have the
hot spots so this term means this
definition that services will be set up
because right now with in third
countries of the so-called Balkans route
are in need of more information in order
to know what are their rights so this is
the main purpose of setting up the
processing centers